have you heard about vid me let's talk
about vid me so last week I wrote a
short tweet thread mocking vid me an
up-and-coming competitor to YouTube for
their rather poor site design hinging on
the fact that they don't look serious
their site layout makes the look empty
and they are apparently so devoid of
content that why I'm leaving vid me
videos are rising to the top it's not a
good look now as things would have it
the thread was seen by Alex Benzer one
of the cofounders of vid me and guy
gunner at me one of the cofounders of
story gommi the platform that powers
maven video both of them were
understandably a bit hurt by the
roasting and implored me with a similar
plea get involved give feedback shape
the future and that is it's a nice
sentiment but no I'm not going to do
that well I sort of am but not directly
what I'm going to do instead is later on
I'll rant at length about YouTube's
failings and let you extrapolate from
their online video hosting is expensive
really expensive an online presence
consists of two major cost factors
storage and bandwidth and video hosting
is kind of the worst of all worlds with
video there's the added fact that your
product your content consists of a lot
of really large files so not only do you
require the kind of high bandwidth
connection of any popular site you also
need a lot of storage to host all of
that content because of this cost
reality it's simple to say that anyone
attempting to build a competitor to
YouTube is in some pretty deep money
anyone who even tries with less will be
bankrupt by the end of their first month
with that in mind you're not paying me
to do products development but I know
you can afford it
you're presumably already paying people
to do research and development for you
and that likely includes people whose
job is to search Twitter
reddit and comment sections looking for
what people have to say about your
product are they talking about it as a
positive as a negative what are they
responding to what's driving them away
I mean vid me already has a front page
meta category for videos about vid me so
research and development are already
part of your business plan or at least
they should be and I'm not going to do
that for free
second the relationship between creators
and platforms is inherently hostile
there's a huge incentive in the internet
age to approach everything as just pals
we're all on the same side we're in this
together get involved help the site grow
the main problem there is that it's not
actually true we're not on the same side
now I as a Content producer and you as a
platform developer have mutually
beneficial goals that are pointed in the
same general direction but our incentive
sets on the granular level are quite
different and diverge as the site's
popularity grows as the site gets more
and more traffic your incentive as a
platform shifts for managing individuals
to managing the product as a whole and
pivots hard towards managing
relationships with advertisers instead
of content creators of particular
importance is that as these interests
diverge the individual creators lose
bargaining power back up the printer's
CEO of a major corporation with land
holdings in 17 states they're on a
burger stand on the desert a national
their [ __ ] local to call back to a
previous point this is why I'm deeply
suspicious of the just pals help the
site grow mentality
we're just pals until we're not any
platform that doesn't codify their
relationship with content creators that
positions the relationship as just pals
and all on the same team without any
structural commitment to that
relationship is ultimately lying it's
easy to say that we're all just pals now
well
the platform is new while its hungry for
content to drive traffic well it's
especially hungry for evangelists that
will do a lot of free marketing purely
by virtue of using the platform keeping
in mind that a great many super
successful youtubers effectively don't
have a website or online presence
outside of the one that exists on other
platforms their YouTube channel is
functionally their website failing to
codify this relationship ensure that the
site will inevitably go through the
change in incentives which will in turn
lead to the decision making that
overwhelmingly favors advertisers at the
direct expense of content creators any
platform that isn't actively courting
already successful content creators by
offering features and services that
those users are looking for is mildly
doomed YouTube is very successful
monolithic even if you simply try to
recreate YouTube who are your users
going to be
well generally speaking it's going to be
a lot of users with small to tiny
channels and it's going to be the people
that were too toxic for YouTube that
second one is a far bigger deal than I
think most people in the position of
platform development really appreciate
if you compete with a monolith the first
people to jump on board will the people
who were tossed off the other ship and
most of them were tossed off for a
reason now this can go either way
there's a lot of creators out there who
are disillusioned with YouTube systems
with the culture on the site the
notoriously awful commenters and the
inter channel targeting and harassment
they haven't necessarily been kicked off
but many of them have been driven away
the key point is that you get the
audience you build and if you don't
build it odds are you're going to end up
with the drags this is why dailymotion
is largely inhabited by automated
corporate accounts and clickbait
pseudoscience peddling diet pills
if a concerted active
effort isn't made to cultivate the types
of users that you want to see then
before you know what's happened
toxic users will have become your core
users and then you're never going to get
out of that hole so when I go on vid me
and the front page has a substantial
concentration of homophobic punditry and
drama channels it doesn't make me eager
to come back it tells me that you don't
know who you want you don't know what
youtubers want and so you're going to
end up with whoever you happen to get
the critical point here is that it shows
you don't know what youtubers actually
want both of the platforms mentioned
maven video and vid me are focused on
monetization which yes is an important
concern of content creators but there's
already a lot of existing viable tabs
for monetization while it's perhaps the
most emotionally pressing issue it's not
the problem that needs the most solving
when you elevate monetization solutions
to the top of the pile when that's the
selling feature that makes you different
from YouTube it tells me that what
you're selling is the image of
profitability to a crowd that is
otherwise not profitable on YouTube well
there is a certain degree of commend
ability in the goal of trying to help
creators at the lowest tiers get more
attention and see some financial reward
for their work I'm inherently cynical
towards any platform that positions
itself in that way without substantial
formalized infrastructure to back it up
because frankly we've seen it before and
it's because of all your support they
were now announcing this big thing
they'll bring us closer than ever before
by creating a new way for us to create
content together in early 2016 the fine
brothers attempted to launch react world
a brand licensing platform on a similar
sort of promise using their platform
would be a great opportunity to get paid
for making reaction videos because you
would get the exposure that comes from
using the react world brand but they had
no control infrastructure to back it up
there was no quality control and thus no
gear
to your performance it was pure
rent-seeking maker studios in early 2017
went through a massive upset that was
years in the making they recruited tens
of thousands of small channels with a
promise of better ad rates high quality
brand deals and the vague promise of
exposure and promotion with no solid
commitments in reality they delivered on
none of those and simply skimmed ab
greven e off the top of the 60,000
channels they had brought into their
network it finally came to a head when
cutie-pies racist practical jokes made
it clear that no one was at the wheel
that maker wasn't in the business of
content and talent development and were
in fact just more rent seekers luring in
creators with poorly backed promises of
getting paid and they stole money from a
lot of people so if you're a new video
platform and your core selling point
your big launch feature is a tip jar
forgive me if I'm having some deja vu
but I'm pretty sure I've heard this song
before I want to stress that point the
launch feature aspect we live in a world
after YouTube YouTube already exists
YouTube already has over a decade of
development missed development feature
creep and general design crust YouTube
has a number of vestigial features that
are good ideas but either they don't
work well or they're functionally
abandoned because they're just tacked on
or poorly implemented any new platform
try to compete doesn't really need to
reinvent the wheel they're not figuring
this out for the first time they just
need to figure out how to make certain
features work how to improve them how to
fold them into the core structure of
their service it's the launch features
of a platform that are going to tell you
the most about a platform's values both
in design and business what features
they consider to be core to the identity
and structure of the platform where are
their priorities there's a lot of
successful youtubers who would gladly
jump ship from YouTube to another
platform if that platform
offered features that on YouTube are
either lacking or just plain bad see
what youtubers actually want is a
platform that will take security
seriously they will care about
harassment abuse malicious use of
automated services will care about
filtering and moderation tools and
collaboration tools YouTube has a
feature that lets you cluster videos
together as a package show but it sucks
and no one uses it and even if you are
using it the user experience is bad and
blame contrast this with how the
now-defunct blip TV structured itself
around serial content blip was far from
perfect but the user experience for
watching something as a show was pretty
good it created a sense of continuity
that's largely absent or at best a
tertiary consideration on YouTube
despite the fact that YouTube is now the
underpinning platform for some full-size
businesses
YouTube structure is still awful at
handling any sort of multi-user setup
let alone properly transitioning from a
personal channel to a professional one
managed by a team if your channel is
attached to a personal Google account
including say your email the only way to
give someone access to the backend of
the channel is to give them access to
the entire account
additionally powers cannot be partition
between team members anyone with access
to the channel enjoys full access to
upload download delete rename moderate
everything this creates significant
security concerns as compromising any
individual member of the team
compromises everything
YouTube's playlist system is functional
but hardly elegant and the overall
structure of the site as a whole makes
it troublesome for content creators to
effectively compartmentalize content
without segmenting their viewership a
secondary channel for specific types of
content is effectively starting from
scratch and needs to be maintained as
its own entity additionally there's no
way for channel managers to effectively
migrate content from one channel to
another without going through the
process of reuploading from scratch
requiring that all
secondary data from names to
descriptions to captions and subtitles
and thumbnails be re-entered manually oh
and you lose existing comments views
votes and so on in the move and these
are just a few of these structural site
design issues with YouTube not even
addressing the cultural problems with a
lack of moderation unclear and unevenly
enforced community standards and easily
exploited automated systems there are a
wealth of deficiencies with YouTube that
could all be centered as a core selling
point for a competitor to bring this
back around I mentioned this but it's my
belief that you already employ people to
do research and development and did some
market research before you even started
building your platform to me that seems
like just a sensible business decision
you need to know your competitors you
need to know your users and you need to
know the market if you don't have that
well it doesn't exactly fill me with
confidence if you do have that and this
is the site that you chose to launch
these are the features that you
considered vital that you figured would
capture the audience that you're looking
for well it doesn't exactly fill me with
confidence
but simply if someone's roasting your
site on Twitter your co-founder
shouldn't be imploring them on Twitter
to submit feedback and make the site
better because you should already know
if you haven't done your research if you
haven't worked systems for security
moderation and collaboration into the
core infrastructure of the site if those
features aren't foundational to your
design then it's already too late it
means that you haven't built a youtube
competitor you've just built a youtube
clone and you're dooming yourself to the
same mistakes a Frankenstein product
built of cobbled together features that
don't properly integrate the charitable
reading is that you're just unprepared
which isn't a good look on its own but
the worst reading is that you're
Drifters
rent seekers looking to exploit the
hopes and labor of content creators and
the internet is already full of those
[Music]